women divorcement 70 to 80 percent of
the time I I would argue in
relationships it's probably similar men
aren't leaving women are so to a guy's
point of view
s girl what is
for you know these hoes you know he
doesn't he doesn't get youth anymore so
he doesn't get either of those things a
lot of times she already has a kid so so
he's not fulfilling his mating strategy
on top of that even if he does find a
good woman that maybe has the qualities
he's looking for she was gonna want him
to marry her right and what does he get
out of that oh she can leave and take
half
and take my kids and she's paid to take
my kids away from me she she gets more
money if she takes my children and so
from the men's point of view they're
just kind of like effort because like
women aren't wives nowadays